let's pull the story from Daily Mail
Biden will finally lift coveted
emergencies on May 11th after more than
three years White House urges 14-week
drawdown to deal with title 42 of the
Border student loans and hospitals so
that's it he's finally putting an end to
the covid-19 National Emergency I mean
we've been I guess we've been out of the
pandemic for a while restrictions have
been lifted Biden said the pandemic was
over when he toured the Detroit Auto
Show in September right and then the
White House was like no it's not it's
not over it's over now
he's ending it that's it there it is he
says the emergency is over in four
months
how are we sure I thought it were an
emergency no no the emergency is over
okay well it's a 14-week drawdown okay
good that's what it is it's totally
stupid yeah according to Biden the
pandemic is over it ended last year Well
there we go everybody congratulations we
did it we can go back to doing
everything but you know what I noticed
um